How many problems would you like to not be?
This is a strange question because you want to have something to fight with.
Do you want to have something
what pulls you the best you have.
You have to have real problems or something like that.
If you get rid of everyone, you'll be lying
on the bed and the problems will put you in your mouth
if all your problems were resolved.
So maybe you want hard problems you can solve
because, I don't know exactly what it is, but overcoming it
and the growth that comes with it.
The effort itself is noble,
you can see it when you have children, for example.
The psychological literature is clear:
if you compare the moments of life of people who have and don't have children,
so people who do not have children are happier.
And so psychologists who tend to misunderstand things, even though they make such intelligent discoveries,
right away - some - draw a conclusion
that if "happiness is a goal,"
so then if something on the kids makes you unhappy, it's not good.
But the moment, maybe it is wrong.
Of course you are less happy with children because you have to worry about them.
My neighbor in the street, a reasonable woman, once said to me:
You can be just as happy as your happiest child.
I thought: that's really good, really reasonable.
But then, if having kids doesn't make you happy, then don't have kids!
Don't be so crazy to be happy, that's the answer!
Because effort is noble: now you are responsible.
You have a new baby; you think, especially if you are a primipar, you think:
What the hell is that? What am I going to do about it?
And you have fun for the end of your life, you never sleep properly
for you will have to worry about it, you have to take care of it.
Why are you good if you don't do that or something like that?
You have not yet been called until you take something similar on account.
It happens that happiness is the meaning of life; it is super to be happy and when it succeeds, enjoy it.
But the idea that you should try to do that is the most miserable.
First, if something terrible happens to you, it's over.
Life must be happy, but what if you get cancer?
What about it? How does this happiness thing work now?
Maybe not you, but your father will get Alzheimer's disease or other damn sickness.
There is an exception if someone has no tragedy with a loved one.
Life is to be happy - that's not true.
We can draw that from those stories, but they don't.
God in those stories is happy to give the people with whom he has made a covenant of happiness and prosperity,
but nowhere is there a word that this is the goal.
The rule is: peace up and hell up!
It is also a rule and constitutes the ultimate ideal of the covenant.
And that will lead you through disasters.
And this is a much more mature view of life.
Just have your eyes half open and see
that elementary reality in life is pain and suffering.
It cannot be avoided. This does not mean that life becomes unbearable,
or that such a thing should not exist. That's not the point.
That means you have to fight it and you have to be ready
and have the will to take responsibility for oneself and others. This is a prerequisite.
And maybe then, if you do well, here and there you get a little luck
you will sit in the evening and have a half hour: your conscience is clean,
you don't have to do anything, you can relax and think:
that's okay, things are good, thank God for that.
And maybe you'll get your luck here.
That's teenage, of course.
And not knowing if anyone doesn't teach you, they should teach everyone!